[Musique]
pour nous disent tout de suite je suis
pas un sportif de haut niveau je pense
est clair jeu non plus un chercheur
révolutionnaire puis je suis ni même un
explorateur téméraire ce que je suis
juste un créateur de marque qui gère les
clients les entreprises à partir de
l'obscurité vers la lumière
donc je vais être en quelques heures pas
existé émile force c'est la réflexion
présidé ce soir c'est un peu ce que je
veux partager avec vous c'est mes
réflexions grande question pourquoi est
ce qu'on existe comme moi vous êtes
sûrement poser cette question là
probablement plus d'une fois dans mon
cas la première fois j'étais aux
primaires et je regardais la classe avec
un certain détachement son voeu qui je
me demandais à quoi ça rime est tous un
peu plus tard rendu à dos la question
était à quoi bon on vient au monde
on va à l'école on travaille pyromanes
c'est pas tellement je joue comme un
concept surtout que moi je rendais à la
troisième étape mais je vous rassure
tout de suite je pense plus comme ça
aujourd'hui je suis souvent d'ailleurs
j'ai comme continue à réfléchir est au
sujet d'un puis après ça j'ai arrêté d'y
penser le temps de m'installer dans la
vie fondé ma famille puis tout ce qui
vient avec ça puis le divorce inclus
puis quelques années plus tard avec ma
conjointe
on marchait dans une rue principale d'un
petit village et comme on marchait on
arrivait face à face où on arrivait tout
près d'un autre couple environ une
cinquantaine d'années et comme on
s'approchait je me préparais vraiment
allé saluer parce que je me sois faire
ce à quoi je me suis séduit les gens et
quand on est arrivé à la distance
presque parfaite pour pour le faire
l'homme et la femme comme deux nageurs
synchronisés ont tourné la tête du côté
opposé
je trouvais ça assez effrayant qui
aussitôt qu'on les a dépassés j'aidais
ma conjointe
je n'étais pas fâché je te laisse un peu
perplexe ben voyons donc son avait-il
des chiens on se serait au moins
renifler le p te vous avez sûrement déjà
vécu un truc comme ça
ou peut-être vous a été de ceux qui ont
tourné leurs regards
moi je me demande qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec l'humain pour quelle justice
qui s'ignorent de cette façon là j'ai
peine à imaginer deux coupes des caves y
en a un qui revient de la chasse est un
qui revient de la cueillette d'une
cueillette qui sera encore dans la
savane puisque les deux s'ignorent c'est
cette expérience a est resté longtemps
moque pas mal longtemps suffisamment
longtemps pour être ici ce soir vous en
parodie et j'ai réfléchi et ça continue
depuis quelques années plus tard
souhaite une rencontre avec des
entrepreneurs que je faisais avec pour
mon travail j'ai posé une question
la question est assez simple qu'est ce
que toutes les entreprises ont en commun
peu importe leur taille importe le
nombre d'employés qu'ils ont peu importe
le secteur d'activité ces gens-là tarder
elles répondent vraiment à cette
question là parce que finalement je
croyais quand même assez simple mais
pour eux semblent être compliqué mais je
les rues je leur ai donné la réponse
dans le fond ma réponse c'est que chaque
entreprise pour exister a besoin de
clients
pas de clients pas d'entreprise c'est
tout simple que ça j'ai poursuivi dans
ma réflexion avec le dire mais pourrait
avoir des clients une entreprise doit
entrer en relation avec ces prospectus
et clientes cible donc pour le faire le
branding ainsi vu son voeu de la marque
fait office de ça c'est la raison d'être
de la marque de créer des liens de faire
la connexion de faire les ponts doit
faire que le client et l'entreprise vont
pouvoir se marier mais c'est quand je
leur ai dit sorte que j'ai vraiment
les chiens en fait sont venus à mon
esprit et je me suis dit le lien et la
cie pour une entreprise les sens de son
existence c'est la relation
pourquoi ce serait différent pour nous
autres c'est dans le fond une entreprise
au sens de la loi ce qu'on dit c'est une
personne morale donc pour exister
l'humain l'homme où la femme doit
inévitablement avoir être en relation
on peut on peut imaginer que si on est
tout seul sur une île déserte reclus
dans une caverne sans aucun contact
en théorie on n'existe pas c'est au
contact de l'autre que ça va se passer
le l'écrivain jacques salomé le dit très
bien dans cette citation là il nous dit
qu'on peut vivre seul mais pour exister
on doit obligatoirement être au moins 2
et le film cast away doit illustrer ce
beaucoup gastriques et seulement ou
encore de la fedex un accident d'avion
on s'écrase devient nos fragiles il est
joué par tom hanks puis dans ce film là
on voit tom hanks créer un personnage
fictif légendaire wilson à l'aide de
ballons pour les bals ou avait mis sa
main dessus
ensanglanté ça crée un certain visage et
ça lui a permis de continuer d'exister
il y avait des discussions avec son
ballon il y avait même des querelles
avec son ballon tout ça dans le fond ça
l'à beaucoup de sens en son absence
chacun d'entre nous ici est présent à
cause de la relation entre son père et
sa mère ses deux ait se sont installés
ensemble et qui est fait on est et on
est ici présents ce soir dans la salle
ce qui m'étonne beaucoup dans cette
réflexion là que j'ai eu c'est de voir à
quel point les entreprises cherchent à
tout prix la relation et que les
individus semblent vouloir
fuir sa vie les entreprises vont faire
beaucoup d'efforts de publicité de
facebook linkedin de toutes sortes de
choses comme ça pendant ce salon
l'individu lui a collectionné des
contacts mais il vaut éviter leur
relation mais son art est pour le savoir
un petit peu plus loin on peut penser
que c'est le sens de l'existence d'une
entreprise ou même de l'individu c'est
la relation on peut penser que
l'existence la qualité notre existence
est intimement liée à la qualité des
relations on va avoir donc une relation
riche égale une existence riche ou
enrichissante
les contacts qu'on va avoir avec
différents aspects de notre vie sont
pense notre relation avec l'argent qu'on
fasse notre relation avec la famille
avec le travail
si on est des bonnes relations avec ces
choses là on va avoir une possibilité
d'augmenter d'enrichir notre existence
c'est de constater que moi j'ai fait il
est une question importante à savoir
mais c'est bien beau tout ça si je vais
avoir une existence riche hommes qui ont
des relations aux riches mais c'est quoi
une relation aux riches on trouve sur
comment on fabrique ça comme un jeu
j'aime pouvoir comparer la relation avec
un investissement pour un investissement
on doit mettre du capital au départ ans
on veut pouvoir aller chercher un
certain regret faut éviter les mauvais
placements mais il faut aussi savoir
profiter des gains que ça va nous
apporter sinon aucun but et ça pour la
relation c'est exactement la même chose
on doit investir quelque chose on doit
éviter les mauvaises relations ont
souvent nous parents nous l'ont dit ses
troupes avec lui
c'est pas un bon garçon ou ce pas une
bonne fille c'est important de penser à
ces choses puisque même chose avec une
relation faut savoir profiter du gain
que ça va nous rapporter
maintenant on s'est un peu comme ça que
ça peut fonctionner mais c'est quoi à
investir dans une relation comme on fait
ça mon investiture une relation avec le
meilleur de soi même le meilleur de soi
même si ce qu'on a en nous si nos terres
et nos compétences et nos qualités c'est
aussi notre temps notre écoute
c'est toutes ces choses quand on est
même sort dans la conversation avec
quelqu'un quand on y va avec un esprit
de contribution inévitablement on va
enrichir la relation
on est déjà en train d'investir un
mauvais placement ou une mauvaise
relation ça peut ressembler quoi parce
que vous connaissez voir disney co mal
tout le monde je promets un certain
monsieur disney avait l'habitude de dire
que votre ou au type de personne le
premier c'est celui qui inspira vraiment
celui qui nous énergise en sa présence
c'est celui qui va
cinq minutes passées avec lui on est
toutes pp on est dans la joie
ça c'est le premier le deuxième type
c'est vraiment un type neutre on gagne
rien on perd aurier il est plus
préoccupé
même si bien intentionnés à son propre
petit bonheur réduit que vraiment
échanger avec nous le troisième type
c'est vraiment l'empoisonneur vous savez
celui que cinq minutes passées avec lui
on a juste le goût de se sauver
on en connaît tous des fois c'est pas
très loin des fois c'est dans la famille
des fois certains ennemis ou ça peut
être aussi un voisin le monde tous ces
gens là en tête
c'est l'idée ce soir c'est pas de vous
dire maintenant on sort dissipons fait
l'inventaire de nos amis ou de nos
relations pied on a en balance la moitié
c'est pas ce qu'on veut faire ce qu'on
va vouloir faire par contre ça c'est de
de chercher à voir des relations avec le
premier type celui qui nous énergie ce
qui nous inspire
c'est ce qu'on va viser line up mais on
peut les en dur et c'est pas tellement
grave
le troisième type ya trois choses qu'on
peut faire avec tous la première chose
c'est de savoir les repérer et de les
éviter
autant qu'on peut parfois c'est pas
possible
parfois font partie de la famille ou si
un collègue de travail on est pris un
peu avec ça à ce moment là on doit faire
une chose qui peut être très très celta
salutaire c'est celle de se désengager
motive mans donc on le prend plus
personnel
donc ces gens là vont nous parler on va
déjà lors être moins infectés par ce qui
passe qui vont faire par des paroles qui
vont nous prononcer la troisième chose
qu'on peut faire avec elles ces
personnes là c'est vraiment de
transformer cette relation là de faire
passer du voile et empoisonneurs un
volet peut-être meurtre ou peu ou même
inspiré comme exemple ça m'est arrivé
dans ma vie à moi
d'avoir un empoisonneur quelqu'un avec
je vais je travaillais venait d'être
nouvellement engagée puis savez ce genre
de personne quand on le voit tout de
suite ont une réaction feeling on a
juste le goût de près de cracher dessus
qui chaque jour je revenais à la maison
que j'étais en füle
j'en parlais continuellement sam
empoisonné la vie c'est vraiment une
mauvaise expérience
comment gérer ça transformer cette
relation là on fait comme on aura réussi
pour former cette relation là puis moi
c'est on a trouvé un point commun est de
points communs qu'on ne trouvait que
c'était peut-être paul meyer mais ça
fonctionne est vraiment très bien pour
nous et si on avait la même opinion de
la haute direction et cette époque une
bonne opinion d'elle et à cause de ça on
a découvert qu'on avait aussi une
certain plaisir à trouver des surnoms à
tout le monde et c'est là qu'on s'est
amusé vraiment beaucoup et - serge c'est
son nom on est devenus les meilleurs
amis inséparables pendant un an jusqu'à
sa mort c'était le plus beau cadeau que
j'ai eu dans ma vie de pour transformer
cette relation ne savait dans le fond
moi je ne sais pas pourquoi l'humain de
la misère ou au point ce que je sais par
contre c'est que pour prendre conscience
de nos relations
parce qu'ils y ont un impact dans notre
vie sur lequel titre sur le final savoir
si on va voir une existence de qualité
ou enrichissante ou non ce que je sais
aussi s'il faut être intentionnel on
peut pas laisser le hasard décider des
rencontres qu'on va faire on doit le
faire vraiment avec intention là on
rencontre quelqu'un de d'y réfléchir de
dire que cette personne là va avoir un
impact dans ma vie parce que je veux sur
l'impact qu'a pas m'apporter ou non sont
destinés au fonds doit prendre la
troisième chose que je sais c'est que on
doit contribuer parce que son contribue
pas on peut pas retirer un gain de quoi
que ce soit
- martin lange existe parce que je suis
en relation avec les gens j'existe
parce que je contribue j'amène le
meilleur de moi même
puis-je existe aussi parce que leurs
contacts
mon identité à moins se révèle puis je
me connaît toujours un peu plus c'est
quand j'étais jeune je souhaitais je
rêvais de changer le monde je le devenir
aussi important que les grandit mandela
ou einstein et ce soir j'espère avoir ce
même un petit quelque chose en vous un
changement de perspective par rapport à
vos relations qui j'espère avoir changé
un petit peu votre mot merci
[Applaudissements]